there are two americas and this other  america  has a daily ugliness about it in one  america you get killed by sleeping in  your car  selling cigarettes or playing in your  backyard you can't ignore this anymore  it's really so sad why we keep loving  this country  and this country does not love us back  it has failed to hear  that the promises of freedom and justice  have not been met  how do we want america to be viewed as  we will continue to use our platform to  speak of these injustices  and demand action for change i got a  grandfather that marched next to dr king  in the 60s and he would be proud to see  us all here  we will be a voice for the voiceless and  until  black lives matter not all lives matter  social progress  never rolls in on the wheels of  inevitability  comes through the tireless efforts and  the persistent work of dedicated  individuals  we must realize that the time is always  right to do right